[Applause]
while we're talking about rape can you
tell us you know can you tell us about
the uncle whatsit rush Russell Simmons
can you break that down apparently
there's this Russell Simmons documentary
bit like mad girls are coming out
talking about him and his defense is I
was [ __ ] way finer girls like
literally apparently his defense is is
if now I was [ __ ] models back then
like if you sorta [ __ ] it's pretty
hilarious
so he's like tone deaf in terms of just
like so some regular people HBO has some
documentary was because he's deaf and
then he just jams a music label
[Laughter]
not just a quick so HBO had a
documentary about Russell Simmons all
the women that allege he like were
misconduct or rape things of that nature
he denies everything the only one he has
compassion for just one girl in the
whole thing and he's like oh yeah I can
understand how she felt like scared in
that moment because like when she got in
my car and then the doors locked and she
thought she was in danger as I was like
but this is a 90s you know like you get
in cars and the doors just automatically
lock so I can see how she might have
misconstrued that time in the car or
whatever but it's like out of all the
girls making these accusations
he's only he only cares about one single
girl also he's been in Thailand yeah
where you can't what's it called like
detain somebody detain somebody and you
know what he's been - oh uh extradite
yeah you can't extradite and you know
what he's been doing while he's in
Thailand [ __ ] these trainees know
yoga
he'd been talking about yoga for 20
years and I am believe they should ever
I'm starting to believe there's a
correlation between rape and yoga not
just Indians guys
yo that's how India's gonna take over
the moon oh that's your defense goal I
need I know that's what he was saying
that they would go rape them but think
about it what did America just reason
recently get and appropriate from India
yoga yoga right what did America
recently start doing a lot right I think
think about it right me too
movement pops up all these rapes were
happening what the 80s 90s 2000s when
does yoga get here 80s pops up 90s 2000s
mm-hmm I think y'all imported that rape
look man I'm not gonna I can't support
you you know I mean yeah I'm not gonna
you you run with this I want you to do
you okay I just can't be Indian and then
be like you're right so you won't have
anything but you go I'm just saying
there's a lot of things here right hey
al you want you know what's the first
position downward dog
that's actually a good point right and
then they give you a position that like
makes it look like you're fighting back
warrior warrior in the shower and just
kind of wash it off it's not yoga dude
hmm it's a complete rape cycle
yeah man beginning to end dude I know
you can't get on board with this but hey
I'm not not I'm not disproven so what do
you think happens with him do you think
he ever comes back like what do you
think this is all yet another another
part I forgot to mention so he said like
oh he doesn't even care about the media
doesn't care about people public opinion
he's only cares about what his daughters
think and so to prove to his daughters
that he's telling the truth
he took nine lie-detector test does that
sound like a person who's just trying to
prove citizens or who's practicing how
to pass I took one PSAT dog I know
probably failed the first eight take
nine anything if you do worry right the
first time
name one thing repeated nine times
before to write publicly in an interview
like he was doing something good you
know what that feels like you know when
you at the carnival game and you try to
throw the little ring on the [ __ ]
milk bottle what you think Marc do you
believe the accusers more considering
that like they're coming out against the
prominent black men like this week oh
yeah but this kind of came out a log
that will go oh really yeah so why is
all the news breaking now just cuz the
documentary just dropped probably yo HBO
is wild for dropping that documentary
right now [ __ ] yeah say what I think
they tried to hide it they put on a trio
max yeah that new yet nobody yet oh yeah
okay how is that different than HBO Go
and they should be oh I know I did
they're only dropping the ball and
nobody nor bro and that's what they
thought was gonna get everybody sign up
yeah during the [ __ ] black lives
matter protest I mean they're [ __ ] up
left and right he's trying to get yo
Peter what's-his-name gotta go yo who's
Peter what Peter knows who the bone
yeah you do that through the scraps yeah
yeah what a hell of a describe smoke
[Applause]
you